Maxime Berton
tétraphobe je suis le résultat d'un
immobilisme
séculaire depuis des
siècles tourne en rond chez les Bert
c'est l'histoire d'un d'un gars qui qui
un moment se rend compte que ses
ancêtres ont fait 4 km en 400 ans et ça
ça va être insupportable et il va ça
gagne
la je me sens pas au bon endroit à ma
juste
place ça n'a rien à voir avec vous
sachele je suis à l'étroit dans ma vie
voilà quand on fait un choix ça doit
être radical on peut pas faire un choix
en demi-mesure alors il va aller à à
l'opposé de ce qui est entendable pour
lui puisqueil parle d'un petit village
on se dit de la façade atlantique de de
l'Hexagone il va partir au Japon d'abord
et puis après il va se retrouver dans un
autre endroit qui est extrêmement
important pour moi bien sûr c'est l'île
de la Réunion à la Réunion il y a qu'un
c'est Chambé
non je cours je préfère traverser que le
faire du Bou ce personnage là qui a fait
4 km en 400 ans il se retrouve sur un
territoire où il y a des habitants dont
les ancêtres eux ont fait plusieurs
milliers de kilomètres parfois pour
arriver jusqu'à cette île donc je
voulais qu'il y ait vraiment cette ce
contraste là et et puis rendre hommage
aussi à à l'île qui m'a fait grandir
tout simplement la Réunion c'est le
pivot le satellite en orbite autour du
monde qui rassemble le trois continents
dans les yeux des
gens la musique sur une scène en
acoustique ça fait vibrer quelque
chose pour moi aussi les choix c'est
quelque chose qui est qui qui me touche
énormément on fait tous des choix et je
je trouve que c'est un thème vraiment
universel le pays de l'esprit du do
do cadeau Donatello là-bas on croit pas
mais les pizzas sont terribles aïe aïe
aïe et qu'est-ce que vous avez envie
chacun votre tour bien sûr que ça laisse
comme comme trace C ce spectacle là et
bien que chacun se se pose la question
en sortant du spectacle moi quel choix
j'ai fait est-ce que moi aussi j'ai été
à à des Carrefour et lesquels ils
étaient et que les gens quand ils
quittent le théâtre se disent il y a un
mec qui nous a parlé là mais il nous a
parlé directement dans le dans
l'intérieur et et ça c'est comme ça que
j'aimerais dans l'idéal que les gens
repartent c'est pour ça que j'écris
cette pièce
bref
[Musique]
patience c'est un artiste que j'adore
parce qu'on a vu plein d'autres de ces
pièces et à chaque fois enfin j'adore il
aborde beaucoup la thématique du voyage
et moi j'adore à chaque fois comment il
décrit les paysages donc vraiment adoré
quand on est allé à la répétition on a
vu ça comme ça ça avait l'air très dur
et puis là aussi quand on l'a vu en
couleur avec les lumières le son la
musique c'était magique moi le voyage
c'est la découverte en même temps la
découverte de soi-même des de de gens de
leurs histoires et on peut en apprendre
beaucoup plus sur nous et sur les
autres